so far we've covered three strategies
for scaling your serverless apps
lucky for critter junction we have three
more upper sleeves
stay tuned
to review critter junction's new wallet
app lets users send and receive virtual
currency
they're using cloud functions to provide
response to queries
around wallet amounts but they hit their
database backend rate limits so they
couldn't experience the skill that
serverless provides
and wondered what other tips they were
missing so my team came in and helped
them set up
instant scaling limits on cloud
functions cloud tasks to limit the rate
of work done
and stateful storage to defer results
from long-running operations
let's explore three more tips number
four
use redis to rate limit requests
sometimes you need to perform rate
limiting in the context of the http
request
for example you might want to protect
your system from abusive users with
per user rate limits like 100 wallet
queries per minute
to control the flow of requests to your
serverless workloads
or you might need a back pressure to the
collar of your serverless workload
like if your wallet transactions called
an api
that checked for fraud which has a limit
of 100 requests per second
you need a defense measure to ensure all
your surplus functions respect that
limit and prevent the api from excessive
use
and redis is great for doing this it
gives you a very low latency
key value data store plus basic data
structures and operations that make it
one of the preferred backing source for
rate limiting
google cloud offers a fully managed
redis service called cloud memory store
if you want to learn how to use redis to
limit cloud function
invocations check out the link below
tip 5 use cloud pubsub to process the
work in batches
when you're dealing with a large number
of messages you might not want to
process
every message a common pattern is to
wait until messages have accumulated
cloud functions integrate with cloud pub
sub a messaging and ingestion middleware
instead of invoking a cloud function for
every message
serverless workloads can use pub sub as
a place to accumulate batches of work
since the service will store messages
for up to seven days
then you can use cloud scheduler a
managed pron job service to process
these items on schedule
you can even trigger the batch processes
based on the number and age of
accumulated messages
this will help you control the flow and
your functions can better handle
increases in trigger requests and
finally our last tip
use cloud run for heavily i o bound work
one of the most expensive components of
infrastructure is compute cycle
when your serverless workload is just
waiting for a remote api call or waiting
for files to read
these are billable moments cloudrun a
managed platform for running stateless
containers
lets you specify how many concurrent
requests it can handle
this can mean big increases in
efficiency for i o bound workloads
for example if the work being done
spends most of its time waiting for
replies from slow remote
api calls cloud run supports up to 80
concurrent requests
on the same instance which shares the
same cpu allocation
what you want to do is one tune your
service performance for the maximum
stable concurrency
two set your expected level of
concurrency
in any code level configuration and
deploy your service
three set cloud run concurrency equal to
or less than
any code level configuration four then
use load testing tools that support a
configurable concurrency
and make sure that your service remains
stable
critter junction now has six strategies
for their serverless scaling
in their back pocket they can use rate
limiting
set instant scaling limits and products
like cloud run
cloud task cloud scheduler and cloud pub
sub to help manage
load on their serverless instance even
highly scalable systems should have
limits on consumption
to reduce the chance of cascading
failures and maximize
throw put for more details on these tips
and an awesome decision tree
check out the link below that's a wrap
for season of scale
stay tuned for more strategies for
scaling on google cloud
and remember always be architecting
[Music]
you